hey guys my name is Jess today is the
18th off November you're watching your
buddies the first expansion for halo 5
guardians is out now and here's all the
details you'll want to know about that
the expansion called the Battle of
shadow and light introduces the 8v8 big
team battle mode and for new big team
battle maps including deadlock basin
guillotine and recurve the update will
also bring 48 new Rex including new
weapons skins armor emblems and a new
shuvit assassination which sounds like
something you definitely probably need 3
bo3 industries have said this is the
first of many free updates planned for
halo 5 and players can expect more than
15 free multiplayer maps by next summer
while the board tools for customizing
your own map will arrive in December
days x mankind divided has been hit with
a six-month delay of pushing back it's
expected launch date to August 23 and
next year previously slated to land in
February the official day sex twitter
account explained Deus Ex mankind to
divide it is a huge project we won't
compromise on quality Ida's Montreal
head David and fosse shared a statement
on the games website where he said the
team is confident and proud of the game
as it stands but they need more time for
post-production he added our aim is for
it to be a worthy successor to human
Revolution and to improve upon that game
in every way possible I know that
expectations are extremely high and we
not only want to meet those expectations
but exceed them we are sorry to
disappoint you with this news finally
another developer has come out of the
woodwork to explain why
microtransactions aren't so bad but do
you guys still don't seem convinced
former uncharted 4 developer Eric
Monacelli who worked with naughty dog up
until November and now works for call of
duty death Infinity Ward defended
Uncharted Seas of microtransactions in
its multiplayer mode monacelli told MCV
if it's good enough content and you want
to pay for it why not pay for it he
called out the paid burst rifle in the
diverse multiplayer as an example of
something potentially helpful that came
out of play research the gun was created
for purchase after release in an attempt
to give inexperienced players a tool to
help them out he added for me the more
thought that's put into DLC the more you
should be able to charge for it because
it's one of those things where you're
creating another game unto itself the
last of us left behind was another game
its work and you should pay for good
work let me know down in the comments
what you think about peg content in
games and if you think they can work
every games but we've got news on a
fallout 4 dialogue mod and Xbox black
friday deals that is everything I have
for you today as always let me know what
matter to you and I will see you again
tomorrow